عنوان عريض للتظاهرات التي دعت لها
تنسيقيات لجان المقاومه وهو احياء الذكرى
الاولى لمجزره السابع عشر من نوفمبر التي
راح ضحيتها 15 من الشباب والشابات غير ان
التباين في الشارع بدا واضحا حول ما تم من
تفاهمات بين المكون العسكري والمجلس
المركزي لقوى الحريه والتغيير بالنسبه
لعمليه
السياسيه
العمليه السياسيه الجاريه اللي هي التسويه
ما بتنسي شارع ولا حاجه فهما بيعوسوا في
عواساتهم واحنا بنعمل في عملنا هذه
العمليه
في الشارع وبنقول انه سنظل في الشارع حتى
نحقق
نظم اليه نحن طالعين عشان لا شراكه لا
مسهومه لا للتسويات نعم للسلطه المدنيه لا
للحكم القحاطه
ويبدو ان التباين لم يقتصر فقط على لجان
المقاومه حول التفاهمات السياسيه بل طال
الحسبه الواحد او قل البيت الواحد الحسبه
الاتحاديه الديمقراطيه الاصل الذي قسمت
قيادته بين موقع على وثيقه المحامين واخر
على وثيقه الكتله الديمقراطيه وهو فعلا
تسبب فيه ابناء الزعيم التاريخي للحزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي الاصل محمد عثمان
المرغني ما استدعى ظهوره بعد غياب طويل
لحسم الجدل
المختلفه ظهور الزعيم كانت له تداعيات
داخل الحزب وهي اعتماد تعيين امين سياسيه
جديده
ومحاسبته محمد الحسن المرغني ترتيب محاسبه
السيد حسن المرغني بتوعه الاتفاق ومشكله
بس لانه السيد حسن مرغي بيتكلم بانه هو
نائب رئيس الحزب ده كلام ما صحيح
حاله الانقسامات التي تعتري المشهد
السياسيه في السودان بين كافه مكوناته
بالاضافه الى تمسك كل طرف بمبادرته
واعتبارها ان هل اصلح لفك عقد الاشكال
السياسي القائم عوامل صعبت من مهمه الوصول
الى حل للازمه السياسيه الراهنه وان تفائل
البعض بان ثمه بوادر للحلي بدات تلوح في
الاوقاف محمد عثمان العربي الخرطوم